on voit beaucoup de merde je me sens
vraiment les lois en toute confiance
voilà alors comment est un vrai
professionnel et or death coil je vais
vous faire une interview conseils de pro
quel est le film qui vous fait toujours
pleurer quel est le film que vous
n'auriez jamais dû voir le film qui vous
fait rire à chaque fois ont deux films
de notre qui est un peu oubliée je
trouve en france qui est toujours calé
le film idéal pour avoir envie de faire
des films toujours morose debussy christ
il faut dire que les tories n'a pas lu
mon film donc ça les conforte aussi dans
des environnements il faut le sujet
donne une cassette parce que sinon on
s'était vus nous la dernière fois
mettant une dédicace étant restée nulle
part ailleurs a dit wak question j'ai
écrit aux futurs grands metteurs en
scène tout mais ce web ont travaillé
grand succès s'était jamais fait voir et
caméras
quel est le meilleur film que vous ayez
jamais vu les mon premier jeu le but
quand j'avais 4 ans le monde pays que
c'est qu'ils aient un petit village du
sud où il n'y a pas le sou des mains
mais une fois par année arriver le
cinéma caméo avec le cinéma on peut
jeter le firm sur un drap un panneau et
la paranoïa mon pays c'est un pays de
montagnes il ya le banc donc l'écran
bouger tout le talent donc je me
rappelle de cette tempête était un film
comique des saluant lui ressemblerait le
libéral dix essais fra diavolo c'est le
film que je me rappelle mieux les autres
grâce à se battre et là ses premières
scènes des plumes au siècle
quel est le dernier film qui vous ait
donné envie de continuer à faire du
cinéma
on ne s'en remet pas je vois j'ai passé
ici est sorti jordan a tous le jundallah
et chantre passé c'est un film sur la
mafia
si chili un film très moral très fort
j'ai beaucoup aimé oui qu'est le film
que vous auriez aimé réaliser que vous
n'avez pas réalisé
ouais ouais c'était bien quand même
le film que vous aimeriez montrer à vos
enfants en leur disant voilà le cinéma
c'est ça chez moi
je me répète sur ma charge je
m'envolerai double secret je suis un
grand père vous être un peu ennuyeux
mais je répète c'est ce que je vous dois
levine que vous avez vu le plus souvent
à seulement pas dans le film qu'elle
jeûnerait voir je les voit très rarement
mais ce match j'ai vu au dictateur j'ai
vu au moins deux fois ouvrait le film
que vous avez envie de voir là vous êtes
impatients de voir maintenant ce n'est
pas encore sorti que vous avez son fils
c'est pas
et bien un problème quand même étonné
c'est que vos films sont très difficiles
à trouver en dvd ou en or ou en vhs et
ça il faut vraiment vous en occuper
parce que tous ces jeunes offert un
coffret il faut qu'ils voient ces films
là dedans mais comment ça oui oui
pourquoi on les voit pape mason d'aider
des voies de distribution que je connais
pas tellement mais à fort et mesures
sorte que je sais je fais des interviews
pour éviter de nous entraîner des
affreux sales et méchants le bal donc
ils vont sortir
soyez patients sur des patients et à
jeter les gants ça sans merci est
tournée